else how much more do we know at the
moment we know that a number of people
have died that there was a crutch what
else
yeah so the official death toll at the
moment is 78 people uh killed I've seen
reports yet to be confirmed that it
could be slightly higher I don't think
you'd be a surprise that the death toll
does rise uh unfortunately because uh
dozens taken to hospital many of them in
a very serious condition now what
happened was a couple of what was
describe as Merchants as a businessman
effectively decided to hand out money to
people who needed it and there are many
millions in Yemen who are in desperate
need of money because they're unemployed
they can't afford basic foodstuffs uh
and and stuff to to live their lives and
so this was part of Ramadan it's it's a
key to the pillar of Islam they're
giving to charity particularly during
the holy month of Ramadan but this was
not an authorized event and so when the
houthi militia turned up and the houthis
the Iranian back Force who controlled
the capital Center they fired guns into
the air to try and control the crowd but
some of those bullets hid electricity
pylons electricity wires causing
explosion and that led people to panic
and then try and flee in in that there
was then the Stampede that have killed
so many people and many injuries as well
and so actually tragic situation not
directly of course linked to the eight
years of fighting in Yemen that has
devastated so much the country and left
Yemen facing really the world's worst
humanitarian crisis but I think the very
fact that there are so many people in
need and were turning up to receive just
around ten dollars so about six or seven
pounds uh just goes to show you what the
fighting has done to Yemen and although
there are
um glimmers of Hope for a peace deal at
the moment in Yemen it is still in a
very very bad condition